[Music]
entropy is the gradual decline into
disorder
i'm always aware of it passing and the
toll that it's taking on all the objects
around me
[Music]
these objects need someone to make sure
that 100 years from now they're going to
be delighting people just as they are
today
i'm an antiquarian horologist
it's quite a rare title to have next to
your name
i work on objects that have a watcher
clock mechanism
[Music]
i am maybe one of two people that has a
masters in horological conservation in
this country
i'm basically a mechanic but a mechanic
from the 17th century
[Music]
i specialize in micro mechanics and i
work on machines called automata
they're made to mimic living things in
the world
human beings birds animals flowers
i think of them as the first instances
of artificial intelligence
everything is self-contained in these
mechanisms
they run usually with springs so it's
not running on batteries it's all
running from just brass and steel
[Music]
anytime i get an object that's broken
there's this innate need to bring it
back
because these objects are so old if i
need a part that i don't have which is
more often than not the case i will go
and make it myself
[Music]
it's the closest you can get to bringing
something to life
you get a silent bird the wings are
broken there's no feathers it doesn't
have eyes
i get to bring all those things back so
that it can sing again
[Music]
i feel they're a significant part of our
cultural heritage
they were made in ways that i couldn't
even do myself they were done by
candlelight they didn't have electricity
so i know they were using a foot pedal
to cut wheels
[Music]
it's an incredible amount of work and
craftsmanship just to create something
beautiful for the sake of that
people believed that these horologists
were sorcerers so in a way i guess i'm a
modern antique sorcerer
you